Guy-Manuel de Homem-Christo and Thomas Bangalter,
more succinctly known as Daft Punk, are arguably
two of the most famous and easily recognisable
musicians on Earth, having won countless major
awards including six Grammys and even managed
a “Best Original Score” award for the
absolutely amazing Tron: Legacy soundtrack.
Despite their extreme success, exceptionally
few of their millions of fans actually know
what the duo look like.
You see, the pair have spent the last decade
or so carefully constructing their robotic
public alter egos, which begs the question,
why?
Though today the pair almost never grant interviews
and go to rather absurd levels to hide their
faces both on stage and in interviews, when
they made their first foray into the world
of music, they had no such reservations.
Prior to Daft Punk both Guy-Man and Thomas
made up two thirds of a rock trio called,
Darlin’ which had lacklustre “success”
from 1992 to 1993.
The band, in which Guy-Man played guitar and
Thomas played bass, released a grand total
of four songs over their brief, six month
long career, two of which appeared on a vinyl
compilation album titled, Shimmies in Super
8.
The album, of which only about 800 copies
were made, is notable for a review it inspired
by Dave Jennings of Melody Maker magazine
who referred to the band’s sound as “daft
punky thrash” (not “a load of daft punk”
as many sources suggest).
This review was read by the duo who subsequently
went on to make it the name of their new band
as they reportedly thought it was funny.
As mentioned, while performing as Darlin’,
neither Guy-Man nor Thomas made any attempt
to obscure their faces.
Although it should be noted that they only
had two real gigs.
They likewise did not try to hide their visages
when they initially formed Daft Punk in 1993
following the break-up of Darlin’.
This all changed in 1996 (a year before the
release of their debut album Homework) when
the band began adamantly refusing to be photographed
or filmed without obscuring their appearance
in some way.
Initially the duo used whatever they had on
hand at that moment to hide their faces during
interviews, such as shaving cream, swimming
goggles and on at least one occasion, a pair
of black cloth bags.
They also would typically wear Halloween masks
for shows.
In 1999, while the pair were in the middle
of recording Discovery, they began to discuss
the idea of constructing alternative identities
that “matched the direction of their music”
and settled on the idea of quite literally
becoming humanoid robots.
To accomplish this goal, Daft Punk approached
two artist friends, Alexandre Courtes and
Martin Fougerol, who created the initial concept
art for what would become Daft Punk’s new
robo alter egos.
They then took this art to renowned special
effects guru Tony Gardner of Alterian Inc,
who began the long process of turning it into
an actual costume.
GortAccording to Gardner, the design of Thomas’
silver helmet was chiefly inspired by the
look of Gort from the 1951 film, The Day The
Earth Stood Still whereas Guy-Man’s helmet
was initially supposed to be entirely gold,
not dissimilar from, to quote Gardner, “a
spaceman’s helmet” before the decision
was made to include the now iconic LED display.
The inclusion of so many LED lights in the
helmet caused a number of issues during the
early phases of construction, forcing Alterian
to bring in the guy who designed the Jumbotron.
To supply power to the helmets, both of which
featured a number of features, such as displaying
text and a variety of patterns (controlled
by a console located on each of their arms),
Guy-Man and Thomas had to wear bulky backpacks
containing a power supply and circuitry, from
which countless wires could clearly be seen
entering the back of the helmet; this added
to the effect, giving the appearance of a
slick of robotic hair.
Speaking of which, up until literally the
last minute, both helmets originally had wigs,
which fit with the early concept art provided
by Alex and Martin.
However, just before arriving at the photoshoot
to unveil their new robotic personas in 2001,
the duo decided to remove the wigs, feeling
that it made them look “sleeker”.
Another issue with the earliest models of
the helmets was how hot it got inside them,
but this was later solved by adding various
ventilators.
Upon unveiling their new look, Daft Punk were
surprisingly coy about exactly why they’d
made the decision to suddenly don robot helmets
and gloves.
When directly asked, Thomas jokingly responded:
“We did not choose to become robots.
There was an accident in our studio.
We were working on our sampler, and at exactly
9:09 am on September 9, 1999, it exploded.
When we regained consciousness, we discovered
that we had become robots.”
When asked if the duo were going to wear the
costumes on stage, Guy-Man doubled down, stating:
“We are robots now.”
Prompting Thomas to add, presumably with a
smirk under that helmet: “We don’t wear
helmets; everything’s real.”
Over the years as the band has softened somewhat
on their stance on interviews, other pieces
of information about why they chose to don
the suits has come to light.
For example, in a 2013 interview with Rolling
Stone, the duo clarified that the robot masks
were not originally for marketing purposes
or to sell records, but to explore the “line
between fiction and reality” and create
“fictional personas that exist in real life.”
Further noting that they thought of the helmets
as “sci-fi glam”, in that they represent
an obviously exaggerated persona that is distinctly
not them.
That said, in the same interview, the duo
noted that the robot personas had become an
unmistakable part of their draw, quipping:
“We’re not performers, we’re not models
– it would not be enjoyable for humanity
to see our features, but the robots are exciting
to people.”
Finally getting to the heart of the original
motivation for the masks, they stated,
We’re trying to separate the private side
and the public side.
It’s just that we’re a little bit embarrassed
by the whole thing.
We don’t want to play this star… thing.
We don’t want to get recognised in the streets…
On that note, a huge benefit of the robot
persona is that, despite their superstardom,
it’s easy for the pair to go about their
daily lives without Daft Punk fans constantly
hounding them for autographs or otherwise,
as Thomas noted, “reminding me of what I
do…
It’s nice to be able to forget.”
And for the curious, yes, despite the pair’s
sincerest efforts to remain masked, there
are plenty of photos out there of Daft Punk
without their helmets, though none of which
we personally have the rights to publish here.
So we’ll just leave you with these links.
(Proceed at your own risk; they really do
look a lot cooler in robotic form ;-)): Thomas
with his wife, actress Élodie Bouchez | Guy-Manuel